okay so K-pop fans are pissed at Faker
but it may not be for the reason that
you think the league goat has just won a
gold medal at the Asian Games and as a
result there's a good chance he will be
exempt from his mandatory military
service Dodge that bullet okay so for
those who don't know in South Korea when
a man turns 18 He is required by law to
serve up to 21 months in the Korean
military by age 28 however according to
Korean law there are reasonable cases
for exemption such as poor health as was
the case for famous actor Kim wubin
during his fight with cancer another
reason to be excused is if a 2B
conscript wins in the Asian games which
was exactly what Tottenham hotspur's
hman son did now this is upset BTS
stands because members of their favorite
group have already begun to serve
fortunately it doesn't seem as if
there's any actual beef between Faker
and BTS